running this Dairy plant has become a
costly business
that's because niger's main electricity
Supply in neighboring Nigeria turned off
the switch after July's military coup
the action is part of the economic and
financial isolation of the landlocked
country by the West African Bloc echoes
the collection of the group the amount
we spend on operating our generators has
increased six-fold the generator's
consumption Rose from 100 liters to 900
liters a day
that he says has eaten into the
company's revenues
it's not alone small businesses and
homes are struggling after the country
was disconnected from Nigeria's
electricity grid
restoring electricity is one of the key
demands of the Junta towards resolving
the political crisis from businesses to
hospitals overheads are rising and some
of the businesses are being forced to
lay off workers
in the mid-1960s an agreement was
reached between Nigeria and Niger to
construct the kainji hydroelectricity
Dam
Nigeria is bound by the deal to supply
Niger with electricity
of power was a breach of that agreement
whatever losses incurred as a result of
cutting Nigeria of tea newborn ecowas
should pay for that the outage led to
loss of lives Nigeria's president and
ecowas Bear full responsibility
but Nigeria is constructing a dam on the
Niger River which officials in Abuja say
runs contrary to the deal there is an
agreement semi-falana has a social
economic rights and accountability
project as long as that agreement
remains valid and subsisting Nigeria
cannot
honor the pretense of imposing sanctions
on Niger
treat that agreement with contempt so
the agreement will have to be respected
if Nigeria wants to bridge the agreement
or wants to set aside the agreement
there is a procedure for going about
that but there's no provision for abrupt
Interruption of electricity Supply to
Niger Republic
the Niger military Junta says it's
stepping in to address the shortfall in
Supply
like many businesses and homes are
without power
the Junta says it will speed up the
construction of the kandaj dam to not
only Supply electricity but to irrigate
farmlands
Idris Al Jazeera near me
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera